that we've had the chance to enjoy
fastball and have was on the privilege
of participating in the talk back about
the film so to get things started I'd
like to introduce my car you saw in the
film professor tar is the head of the
department of psychology and studies the
neural cognitive and computational
mechanism underlying visual perception
and cognition and I'm pretty sure he's a
baseball fan too right it's a professor
tar it's my honor to turn the microphone
over to you to start the panel
discussion thank you very much our panel
tonight it's kind of fading it now um
okay thank you our panel tonight we have
Jonas and of course you all met so we're
going to come up here so we can take
questions on the stage we have Chris
Johnson misses it's not working right
sorry listen to talk can probably hear
me anyway um John's actually otologist
but also happens to be the director on
how you handle some of these things and
then where's Greg there's Greg who's our
star physicist in it and I could mention
also that timber Steinem is on the west
coast of semester so he's not here right
now and they notice to making tempura
signs in the West Coast semester and
Nathan urban is now at the University of
Pittsburgh airplanes vice provost and
couldn't be with us tonight so I want to
open up to questions you probably have a
lot of questions and I want to start
with one of my own sexually for Chris
what's the deal with Nolan Ryan I mean
I'm not much older than him when he
finished picking and it's like day you
know 100 pitches are out so what's going
on what happened to that people like him
so first of all just an amazing job of
capturing really the both the brilliance
and the unique is if somebody like a
Nolan Ryan that could have film so I
think even for non baseball fans you're
in a marvel at somebody's ability to
perform at that level for 27 years I'm
45 right now I know five years ago is
when I started to feel like your body is
not the same anymore I can't imagine
doing that and so how does somebody do
that i mean you know in some respects he
won the genetic lottery and in other
respects it's it's a part of how we
trained and there's the nonspecific
factors the the x factor the mystery
that everybody's after i get asked a lot
what what is the what's the X Factor all
you guys look for when you assess there
isn't really an X Factor there's an A
through Z factor but it he had a lot of
it so it doesn't it doesn't help when
you try and go out and find somebody
like that because I think they even made
reference to it in the movie that he
didn't even know how competitive he was
and that is that is difficult to get
around those are latent constructs a
psychologist that's what we do we look
for latent constructs they're hard to
measure but we're trying to predict on
an 18 year old young man what is going
to be like for the next 20 years it is
really difficult so the short answer
your question is if we knew exactly what
that
was and how he was the way he was we'd
be picking out the guys who had and we'd
be trained everybody to it so it's still
a mystery thank you I forgot was that by
the way today is Jackie Robinson
actually in the major leagues and
they're honoring Jackie throughout the
entire major leagues and Thomas told a
producer this movie also made another
movie called 42 which is the story of
Jackie Robinson's life and he was nice
enough to donate 25 copies of that movie
if you look in your programs you may
have 842 emblem in there and give a 42mm
in there actually see someone in the
back court that corner over there
afterwards you can pick up a copy of the
movie so thank you to Thomas for that as
well so so excited so before we take a
couple classes committed Jonathan you've
probably seen the movie innumerable
times is there anything strikes you knew
every time you see it or not well on the
subject of Nolan Ryan one thing that if
you watch the movie on iTunes there's
some DVR some itunes extras that are
things that we were on the cutting room
floor but we're interesting and we
assembled them for for extras he tells
the story in 1986 he had some soreness
in his arm he was 39 and after the
season James Andrews the famous surgeon
examined his arsenal that news is torn
you're going to need surgery and at that
point it was a year and a half before
you can even think about coming back so
he said I'll be 41 years old doesn't I'm
not going to have surgeries so he just
went home and said he usually started
throwing on December 15 so this year
because of the arms that I'm not going
to try
so in january fifteenth he went out to
throw and it felt fine and he went to
spring training and starting pitching he
felt fine and dr. Andrews came through
Astros cabinet examined him and he said
it healed this is the first arm I've
ever seen that healed itself and it was
like some kind of mystical experience
and then flash forward seven years when
his elbow pops when is pitching against
the marriage and the next spring his son
was bitching at at TCU he was playing
college ball for TCU so no one was down
hanging around and he's went to pitch
batting practice one day and his arm he
said my arms fine it felt fine I said
you could have come back he said you
know I could have been the owner of the
Rangers called me he said I hear you're
itching why don't you come back and I
thought about it and I said you know if
I can't give you 200 innings I just
wouldn't feel right taking your money I
could probably give you about 180
innings but the getting my arms fun is
just getting the rest of my body ready
to pitch every fifth day was it was so
hard the last year he said that it was
just everything he could do to get back
on the mound and he just couldn't go
through that again if he didn't think he
could make 200 so just the mystery of
Nolan
sort of deepens the more you know the
lessons it's sort of believable as
little ration Greg is there anything you
noticed or thought about since you last
saw the film well we cap up there are
more fast pitches right button but not
reaching look Nolan Ryan would give but
there's more David look at and so not to
have more confidence in what those
results look like you're pretty
confident on the 108 I think I'm very
confident Eve order what kind of do air
you want to put around the 108 might be
half a mile per hour or something like
that Jonathan didn't want to show that
part of the movie yeah one of nice day
they could give or take it off the dock
31 is so let us say so I'd like to open
it up for questions from people there
another bike to bring do back there is
there anyone else in custody to like to
ask okay
hitter actually it's basketball going
that fast when are they meeting decision
to swing in their brain because we
talked about the you know the second in
the milliseconds it takes to make the
decision and actually sleep cause you do
see hitter is hitting possible that are
right so I think with Kris and I will
probably something to say about this but
the rate of it you move your eyes is
such that you probably get to look at
the ball somewhere around the midpoint
depending on how class the ball moving
but really at that point you're not
going to get to see the bubble again
until it's really crossing play these
are odd when your eyes are moving or
essentially blind and see your eyes look
at the ball you're blind and you have to
have already decide to man because also
the time it takes to plan your swing and
actually execute it takes a confirmative
time you really it's probably in the
first couple hundred milliseconds at
that point of committed entirely which
is what I suspect it's exactly why you
know I forget who was acid a look like
Bugs Bunny spinning around they do
embarrassed so someone to go after which
is it affordable it's because they've
already made a decision but where they
think it's going to be and they get
problems a curve ball or something
they're completely off yeah that is a
fascinating things for watching what are
the things that I has been most
interesting to me is that I have a
built-in lab at either end of the
spectrum of being able to do this I have
a an 11 year old son who is a baseball
fanatic and and then every day I'm with
guys who are the best in the world at
this and so one of the things I remember
is is teaching the young kids when your
head when you're in the batter's box and
you're preparing you need to be going up
there
I'm going to swing unless I see
something I'm not good that I don't like
so many of the young kids when they see
somebody throwing a ball at them they
get you know there's a lot going on in
the head but so many of them their first
approaches well let me determine if it's
something that I want to swing it and by
that time even at that young age by that
time if you're still determined whether
or not you want to swing it it goes by
too fast and so you're developing these
young eyes and these young brains and
this psychomotor reaction at a young age
to get up there and think I've got a
swing unless it's something i don't want
and so every now and then with the with
our big-league manager Clint Hurdle I
have conversations about the
neuroscience of baseball and and one of
my favorite quotes our client is a he'll
say look all I know is that I can't
think and hit at the same time and so
there's a very automatic reaction going
on the ability to inhibit that swing
some people are better than others but
there's definitely something going on
you know preconscious levels I mean it's
it's faster than awareness
too much a data phone for example to go
too much
delivery in a windup you know how people
I don't even like for example cam and
arrows throws very fast and then people
seem to be able to hit them so you know
you're it's a hundred but then guys are
not going all over the place and then
someone else it's very different also in
addition to just being able to track it
and hit it when pitchers have any amount
of deception or whenever you can perhaps
pick the ball up earlier in the pitch so
there are all these subtleties that are
are difficult to quantify I think we get
there at some point the number of
metrics that we're getting now is is
really impressive I mean it every major
league baseball stadium now we're
getting a spin rate on every pitch so
it's fascinating we're getting I mean
we're getting movement of the ball in
three dimensions so in addition to just
the speed there's the movement of the
ball and there's also the deception of
the picture has before he throws so and
then you added stress because these are
not robots these guys have emotions and
they have egos and they have
expectations and you put all that
together and you've got beautiful game
of baseball you know i would say Rod
Carew I had a conversation with him
about this issue and
that the pitchers that he can pick up
the ball when it's still in their hand
and it makes sense if you think about
what what Mike and Tim were saying in
the film about how many extra
computations you get when you know when
the balls moving a little slower it's
really moving a lot slower in the
pitchers hand right and rod carew said
if I see it in his hand and I know what
kind of pitch it is based on the grip
because their vision is so amazing that
he's I head if it's a thousand miles now
if I see it earlier and that so to me I
think that that deception begins in the
find of us probably why Gossage was so
successful because okay with that stands
a part of the reason to take care of
such a tough pitcher hit is because
every pitch looks the same looks like
kind of thumbs upses hand it's
impossible to tell what's coming because
that is that true Chris for absolutely
yeah very very difficult to tell what
she's going to throw ya think of a
little more leverage because of how much
for hiding what's happening until the
ball actually across this point and i
would think confidence he said you know
so much of it is really the stress or
lack of stress and i think that if the
batter thinks he's picking up the ball
early he's so much likelier to hit it
even if he's he's only picking it up a
tiny bit early or maybe not even picking
it up earlier thinks he is you know like
Clint Hurdle said you can't think and
hit right so if you're if you relax
because of your confidence your
everything's just going to flow better
so I have a question at some point in
the movie that is this representation of
people running faster and faster while
the pitching is not getting faster there
is an Olympic sport where people just
saw a fixed weight and they look at how
far they throw it I wonder if in that
sport people can throw it increasingly
further and it can be a comparison
between the two to understand what makes
this change in human performance in one
case versus not being able to throw
faster that's a great question we should
look into that and see I have a feeling
that I guess the javelin is is a
throwing but there's my shop hood is
more brute force than speed anyway it's
a really interesting question it is
interesting that more and more pitchers
throw article major feat remember before
so the number of great pictures we have
now seems almost impressing them at what
time yeah I think it is I think clearly
there are more pitchers throwing at this
maximum but I've been asked this
question so many times during the
process of screening this film and the
analogy that that I came up with was
it's like the human lifespan like ever
since time immemorial they say a hundred
and twenty years someone correct me if
I'm wrong is the longest a person is
going to live and that's the same now as
it was maybe 2,000 years ago 3,000 years
ago but a lot more people are getting
closer to that now then ever did before
because nutrition because of it all
those other things and now you see in
Major League Baseball there's still that
limit that you can't throw faster than
but so many more people because of
better mechanics even better you know
nutrition workouts and also because the
nature of the game now caters to
throwing as fast as you can because if
you're starting you're only going to
throw five or six innings you can throw
on your pitches and then everybody who
comes in from the bullpen is throwing
one inning tops and you know and so
everybody has the opportunity to just
let it go as hard as they can every time
they come in and that didn't used to be
the case because when you have a starter
knew he had to throw nine innings he
wasn't going to push it as hard as he
could he had to pick his spots that's
wife when it Bernie banks are talking
about Robin Roberts when guys were on
base all of a sudden it was really fast
now guys are just you know can throw it
because they're not expected to stay in
so I think it's a combination of all
those factors and either the game is
following the trend or creating the
trend but it's it's certainly true then
you know there are hundreds of pictures
now throwing north and 95 right I like
your analogy of the human life span one
another analogy that I didn't go to its
Roger Bannister and his in the mile time
that you know I didn't it was just
accepted that no one can break the
four-minute mile and and you know nobody
did for many many years and innocent
roger bannister did it the following
year there were 12 other people who did
it and so this this gets into the
confidence piece in the art of what's
possible and just knowing that this can
be done in every year we have some new
record being set and baseball and so
there are incremental changes in records
being broken but not on the grand scale
as you see other another sports for sure
my question is um throughout the process
of making this film or like otherwise is
there a player that stands out to you
guys as someone like I guess a favorite
or most memorable experience someone
specific that you met and talked to and
like what wasn't about them well for me
talking to Hank Aaron I'm talking to
Nolan Ryan were for the batter and the
pitcher that was incredible I mean
sitting and talking about the fastball
of Nolan Ryan for a couple hours in
Texas was like you know climbing the
mountain into bed to see the seek truth
from the kuru anatomical again it just
tells you all the truth like I felt I
left the room like I know I know it all
there's no one right the Bob Gibson
interview which was conducted by Mike
Tolan who was one of the producers of
the film amazing Academy award-nominated
film maker Bob Gibson was it was
incredible I mean here's a guy who
supposedly hates talking to the media
and doesn't like doing these things but
you know there was Thomas hall of fame
behind it
he said he would do it and he was just
amazing you know I I love why I could
watch that that section and again in the
iTunes extras there's even more more
stories he talks about going after guys
and you know when he he talks about
respect and some guy on them that's John
Milner swell so hard in a preseason game
the NEX officiate he swung so hard and
fell and he said that is no respect so
the next pitch oh my god and then later
that season Tom Seaver through one right
over his head and he said I think there
was like Tom Seaver throw my my head and
I remembered jogging on the spring
training ok this bear and they're like
four or five more just great great
stories so those those are the three I
would say yeah you know Ryan and Aaron
that I that I did and Mike's interview
with Bob Gibson her really my favorite
and when meeting Steve down Kowski was
another really interesting experience
another one with more than in the iTunes
extras but the situation with him in
case you are curious is he was diagnosed
with what's called alcohol-induced
dementia and when he was found after 20
years of no nobody knew where he was he
had become a migrant farm worker in
California he was picking you know
peaches and oranges in the fields and
his sister finally found him after 20
years he couldn't even speak anymore and
he's had a lot of therapy and he's doing
better
Connecticut but that was let me talk
about a mythical figure and knows I was
really cool to to beat him we had a
great day together maximum then maybe
it's because I'm making stuff up like
the cells themselves a break down any
concrete problems like there's some
mechanism that that says that this is
why you know 122 Mexico so is there is
there some bottle night that makes it so
that humans can't hitch more than 105
110 you know something in the body
that's preventing us from you know
breaking that record I think maybe Greg
can address this about you know moving
something that shape that size that
weight that certain speed requires a
certain amount of force and not you
maybe take a swing of what so native
urbanchat addressing few others are
butters the biology well I think they
would say that there are limits of just
the what our muscles and what our bones
can do interact the limit of what one
can do safely and maybe our body then
that's not an accident that we're not
capable of destroying ourselves I don't
know if I believe that or not IV because
I don't know how that translates all I
can be run a fast
grow further so why answer is I don't
know one last question thank you in the
making of this film did you ever have
any discussion about other sports that
are not as structured as baseball
something such as soccer where you're
going to your body is what you're
hitting the ball with your either
deciding do I use my head why use my
knee toys my foot will use whatever or
handball something like that baseball is
predictable somebody's standing on a
mound throwing that ball at you you know
what your reaction should be swing and
hit ideally but it's still a predictable
outcome other sports where there is no
predictability did you have any
discussion about them well we weren't
going to talk about any sport other than
other than baseball but I think what
you're talking about really gets at the
beauty of baseball and then that it's
predictable but what's predictable is
something that's been set up in such
perfect balance that when you have the
person at the one end performing at the
limits of what a human can do the only
person who could possibly hit it is
somebody at the other end of performing
at the very limit of
what a human can do and the other sports
have their own fascinations in the
randomness of how people respond to a
more random situation in the creativity
of a soccer player who can receive the
ball from anywhere and take it anywhere
it's a whole other kind of fascination
but the drama in that fastball pitcher
versus a great hitter within those fixed
parameters and still anything can happen
any pitch that's that's why baseball I
think is is so amazing the thing it's
better than the other sports but it that
can find drama yielding infinite result
is is this is really fascinating might
be better than all other sports it might
be like thank you all for coming and
thank you so much payments for
participating Johnny